Gary vaynerchuk where does it end with  you ever it doesn't ever end because all  of it is just human behavior and it's  just one big game of insecurity and  actual confidence and everything in  between that's why life can be simple  money awareness friendships relative  relationships everything is based on how  you feel about yourself actually and the  more you understand that everybody else  has problems too and everybody else has  this too and the more you can start  being nice to yourself then everything  becomes easy and so it doesn't end  because the business question the  parenting question the marketing  question the hobby question it's all  about this